we fear the future
because we are wasting today
the best way to succeed in life
is to act on the advice we give to
others the problem with the world is
that we draw the circle of our family
too small
when you don't have anything
you have everything
profound joy of the heart is like a
magnet that indicates the path of life
love begins by taking care of the
closest ones
the ones at home
let us always meet each other with a
smile
for the smile is the beginning of love
some people come into our life as
blessings
some come in your life as lessons
if you are successful
you will win some false friends and some
true enemies
succeed anyway
if you are honest and frank
people may cheat you
be honest and frank anyway
what you spend years building may be
destroyed overnight
build it anyway
if you find happiness
people may be jealous
be happy anyway
a life not lived for others is not a
life
i prefer you make mistakes in kindness
than work miracles and unkindness
work without love
is slavery
be happy in the moment that's enough
each moment is all we need
not more
discipline is the bridge between goals
and accomplishment
there is more hunger in the world for
love
and appreciation in this world than for
bread
if we really want to love
we must learn how to forgive
life is a song sing it
life is a struggle
accept it
if you are humble nothing will touch you
neither praise nor disgrace
because you know what you are
[Music]
be kind and merciful
let no one ever come to you without
coming away better and happier
we cannot give
what we have not got
life is an opportunity benefit from it
life is beauty
admire it
life is a dream realize it
do not allow yourselves to be
disheartened by any failure
as long as you have done your best
life is a challenge we must take it
be faithful in small things
because it is in them that your strength
lies
poverty was not created by god
it is we who have caused it
you and i through our egotism
if you are discouraged
it is a sign of pride because it shows
you trust in your own powers
one filled with joy preaches without
preaching
do not wait for leaders
do it alone person to person
we do not need guns and bombs to bring
peace
we need love and compassion
never worry about numbers help one
person at a time and always start with a
person nearest you
you are greater than you know
i used to believe that prayer changes
things
but now i know that prayer changes us
and we change things
life is a game play it life is too
precious
do not destroy it
one of the greatest diseases
is to be nobody to anybody
we have to possess
before we can give
it is not how much we give
but how much love we put into giving
live simply
so others may simply live
the first requirement for prayer is
silence
people of prayer
are people of silence
i don't do great things
i do small things with great love
a man doesn't leave a woman who does not
hold a man
any country that accepts abortion is not
teaching its people to love
but to use violence to get what they
want
only marry a man
who has a lot of patience and kindness
even the rich are hungry for love
for being cared for
for being wanted
for having someone to call their own